I was very interested that so many of
you did Part D but you get a party did
Pardee before doing putzie part 2 okay
so just to remind you this is the
question right you're trying to graph
this lockers now the fact that part d is
there after party part two is kind of
Lee winking at you to say hey you know I
know you can find you can graph this
without appealing to any algebra you
shouldn't need to if you appeal to
algebra to do this and Part D wasn't
there you just spent five minutes of
your time that you're going to regret at
the end of the paper okay think about
this what does this mean you've got two
points that you're comparing to right
you're comparing to your measuring the
distance from I and you'll measure the
distance from careful minus 1 plus 3i
okay because really really that's
actually said take away negative 1 plus
3i okay so be me you're comparing to
those two points all you needed to say
was where's i won what I there which is
actually just once just one please minus
1 plus 3i minus ones re all rights you
in this way then you go one two well
already gone three there we go there's
minus one plus 3i and you want all of
the points that are equidistant to these
guys you should know by now that's just
the perpendicular bisector right you
should see that you've been doing lock
us into unit and extension one for a
long time now okay this is kind of two
unit just dressed up in four unit
language okay yeah okay now once you
here's the thing right oh yes and no so
you would have to find them they're not
hard to find though in terms of just you
know actually like you think I chose
very easy numbers for you okay the great
it ends up being just a half but the
point is that like when you see Part D
there and it's like oh this is when I
need algebra okay that tells you you can
just sketch it what we're looking for is
number one it's a straight line number
two the straight line that is is that
perpendicular bisector right so in fact
the main thing I was looking for with
these points and that your mind match
that
okay i was looking can you recognize
this kind of feature and a lot of you
did not which is why you went straight
for the algebra like you I put Part D in
there so you actually got rewarded for
that but you didn't need to okay all
right now here's why I did this some
question in this order right I'm going
to do part two rather new part 1 okay
tell me just humor me for a second okay
what is the lock is that I've actually
drawn on where is how would you verbally
describe it humor me obvious question
it's this straight line right it's got
great and a half it's got a y-intercept
all 99 and for tuna quarter okay it's
that lion right do you agree that it's
completely unambiguous that this line is
part of my lockups do you agree with
that yeah okay what if I just changed it
a little bit what if I like shaded some
stuff over here okay is this line still
part of my lockers it is right all I've
done is add some stuff you all agree
that this like drawing a straight line
means I think all of these points are in
the lockers right yes okay now have a
look at what the real answer was which
almost no one dear for part one ok
firstly let's do the easy part okay
you've got this argument is pair of
arguments right see you between minus 2
pi and 3 and between minus platform
right so you're in this little region
here okay and then the imaginary pyres
to be above negative 2 no big deal I'm
above okay now all of those people who
miss the full marks just said what you
know I'm just going to draw some lines
I'm just gonna you know I'm just going
to draw lines like down on all use red
just okay how upset I am okay I i drew
this line over here and i drew this line
over here over here over the i'm sure
the volume because why not right are
those lines part of the lochus know is
what I screamed like 18 times as i was
marking this okay if you have written
down draw those lines as part of your
wall i'm not sure where
it that's fine use pencil and get rid of
them later like a very small number if
you did but you really should have been
indicating they were dotted and almost
no one indicated these boundary points
Eva which are kind of important okay
sure how to answer this question okay so
i was driving her from the city like two
weeks ago and on the side of the road
with two cars that crashed into each
other on this road people have crashed
into each other does that make it okay
that people have done this in the past
no it's a freaking car you all agree you
all agree that's the walkers I drew a
straight line it's in the lockers right
just because you added some shady or
doesn't mean it's suddenly not in the
lockers okay if you don't want those
lines as part of your region then either
get written completely or doctor which
is what I did okay it's really really
important communicate clearly why is
there it open circuited circle at the
origin because you cannot measure an
angle at the origin from the origin
right it's a little bit I'd say okay for
any of you i can get my i can get my
compass outlook and i can i can measure
my angle to you right and i can say all
right 359 degrees whatever it is okay
what's the angle for me to myself and
the answer is it's whatever i wanted to
be okay so there's no meaningful okay
yes how much you got them you wait like
that ok so number number one don't draw
your graphs in pen i draw my crashes in
10 cuz i'm awesome okay but no even like
you really shouldn't write like it's so
you're constructing of course your
construct you write like you're like I'm
not sure where it goes and then you
realize all this parts mr. year and this
plant specific out use a pencil use a
pencil you cannot use white out to fix
your pen graph right because you can't
use white out in the HSE so don't use it
right use a pencil or here's a simpler
way this is a boy when you're starting
off right so you like my k minus 2 pi on
three it's going to be an able some like
that- plan for something like that you
don't know any of these parts are in so
draw the whole thing dotted right draw
the whole lot and then you do your minus
2 and i said ok now i know where i have
right and everything is uh i think all
the boundaries are inclusive right all
the in qualities so you say I can't be
there I can be there I can be there and
then you fill in one two three
everything else and you're done it's not
that complicated